SKRatAdu
Whats up my nen! Lets do this guys.
Skratadu Floradu
Stop it.
Skratadu Floradu.
In case your new here on this channel guys, what we do here is every Friday we watch the most hilarious clips
We could possibly find and we try not to laugh. (and end up laughing every time)
Now to accept this challenge 'GUYS'
Is to SMASH like.
Smash like if you win, and smash like if you lose
It's a new show (Not)
I'm trying it out.
But anyway guys,
Lets freaking dO tHiS
First off, I challenged the irish green person  (Hey at least he has original content)
He took the challenge FINALLY.
You know what, i got to recognize it. Mark however,
Not a word.
HES ON VACATION GODDANGIT-
I bet he's shaking.
He cant sleep at night.
Oh, I never reacted PewDiePie's reaction video.
That's what he's thinking.
PEWDS IS UNAMUSED
Mark, whats wrong with you? How can you laugh at this?  This is so sad.
This is so sad.
Alexa, can we hit 50,000 likesss
*Points at Alexa* Jack is making fun of you!
Alexa are you just gonna take this?!?
You're a coward just like Mark, Alexa.
It is the most advanced iPhone we've ever created. And i'd like- TO TAKE MORE OF YOUR MONEY
BECAUSE BASICALLY I"M MONKEY
I mean its a good-
I am not laughing! (no one said you were) I am not laughing!!!
But that's a good meme. That's a basically a monkey that's just snook out of nowhere
Basically i"m monkey!
Me too!
Me: hi baby My cat:
*DEMON NOISE*
Oh, i bet you. I bet you 99% of people laughed.
*ANOTHER DEMON NOISE*
*PLEASE STOP TORTURE*
Pewds screaming: WHAT IS HE DOING?
Don't ever explain the context out of this.
The fact that I have no idea where this is from
Just makes it so good.
Give me a good one.
Give me a good meme.
Hey! Look its me! (Yeah we know.)
*EARRAPE*
NO
What are you doing Felix!
You're not supposed to laugh!
It feels very real.
Look! Like I'm wielding this gun.
People should not let me wield a gun.
I mean, how do you talk like that?
I've said this before. But i'm amazed.
I'm amazed by his accent.
Vield, we should not let people vield (In really bad accent)
I cannot, I cannot be more Svedish when i talk.
Can you tell.
Can you tell?
See? I can't even fake my own accent!
*Pewds dying*
Empty your bullets!
Put in one bullet.
So you have one bullet in the gun, yes?
I do.
Okay. Me too.
So let's close the gun
Your turn
Oh okay.
My turn
OH I SURVIVED
Your turn
OHH okay my turn
OHH okay your turn
AH HAHA
Okay my turn
OH your turn
*Dabs*
Sorry for not putting subtitles on what they were saying. I'm lazy...
My gun is f*****g empty! (family friendly)
Ohhh my god
Wait. Did we just oh my god at the same time? Oh that's beautiful.
We're not going to top that. That's beautiful.
lilfatherfigure he always does good memes.
Stoppppp please ninja
On March 15 an online explosion occurred when ninja is joined by-
It really bothers me how ninja doesn't tie his pajama pants.
Like I get it you're wearing it as a meme,
But at least tie them. You're not a savage.
Hiphop artist Drake for a game of Fortnite
*ZOOMS INTENSIFY*
I knew it.
I knew it was time for drake to rise up.
We have infiltrated the highest level of your "mainstream" society.
Prepare and fear the day that gamers will finally rise and take our rightful place as the leaders of (THE WORLD)
of one something! (strong speech there pewds)
Hey! You know what? Captain Marvel looks great. I actually really want to see it now.
Is that the actual trailer?
Wait, wait, sorry wait, hold up. What is the context here? What's the context?
Oh my god!
Woman came through the ceiling dropping about 25 feet
Patrons screamed
Ah that's hilarious.
She WAS LOOKING FOR THE BUS STOP!
She was looking for the bus stop. Of course!
Sorry, sir! Where is the bus stop?
IN THE CEILING
I'm notorious for hating Marvel. Okay? I don't like 'em. But can someone explain,
I know this is the kind of thing
Where I will- I will make a statement and everyone will fill me in and I will feel like an idiot. (Pretty much)
But why is she called Captain Marvel? Is that not the dumbest name? (I've heard worse - PewDiePie?)
I have ever heard for a superhero. What is next? Mr. DC universe person. Hey look! There he is!
What the heck? What the frick guys? I don't get it. Can you come up with any more?
It's like you ran out of names. What should we call Captain Marvel, copyright also now by Disney what the frick guys?
Oh man
Props for their creativity.
It's like you make these random noob movements their like:
I have no idea how anyone would implement that into anything.
HUWAAAAAAAAA
Did I just run through a sheep?
Oh
Special Move: High Kick!!
HA
HAH HAH HAH HAH
HA is that all you got?
*ded*
Alright.
So finally,
You guys have been asking me to watch this video.
uhhh
Alright I need subtitles
Nice to meet you too. (Look at him. Being nice. Aw.)
Thank you.
Oh, great!
No, why?
That's alright. I do the same thing all the time. (everyday)
There's no shame
Yayyyy!!!
I'm happy too.
I'm very happy to! This is so fun.
What?
I can't.
Uh-huh. This is too sweet. I can't.
♫ [ Nic & the Family − Homo Nee Momoko ] ♫
*Pewd's horrible dance skills*
MoOoOOOoMoKo!! *the singing starts*
♫  Nee nee Momoko, anone Momoko  ♫
( Hi hi Momoko, hi there Momoko )
♫  Nee Momoko, anone Momoko  ♫
( Hi Momoko, hi there Momoko )
Thank you for watching!
Another episode of you laugh you lose!
SMASH like if you enjoyed!!!
SKRATADU FLORADU
♫  Nee nee Momoko, anone Momoko  ♫
( Hi hi Momoko, hi there Momoko )
♫  Nee Momoko  ♫
( Hi Momoko )